[Music]
seven not ninth 26 was a good age I
liked it
lots and lots of good things happened
the last day of being 26 was a great day
I woke up came downstairs and watched
about a hundred nerdfighters give me the
best birthday greeting I had ever had
and then about halfway through the day
my people got a call from John Kerry's
people and when I say my people got a
call I mean one of his assistants sent
me an email asking if I would like to
interview him yes I I would like to
interview John Kerry but that was a nice
birthday present and then Katherine took
me to see spider-man 3 which was really
bad I mean generally I like any movie
that's loud enough that I can fart
during and no one will hear it but I
like at least a little bit of depth I
feel I could just shaved everything off
the top and decided well what do we need
a writer for oldest pay three hundred
million dollars for special effects and
everyone will go see it you know they
were right but that doesn't mean that's
what they should do what's important is
that we got a call before the movie
started and it was you John calling to
tell us that Neil Gaiman had posted open
to brother 2.0 on his blog who there's
no much better than having someone that
you're a big fan of be a fan of
something you're doing it just feels
good thanks Neil and then we came home
and read Brotherhood 2.0 comments and
eight mini corndogs my girl knows how to
make me happy additionally from
Katherine I received Mountain Dew
pop-tarts and a chocolate bars
this one has baby rhinoceros chunks in
it and from people besides Katherine a
jet black cowboy bebop action figure
from my dad from brian jim beam black
from melissa an anatomical gummy heart
and from Kelly this amazing nerdfighter
shirt
the nerdfighters United oh wow I'm gonna
do it I'm just you know I might as well
do it on camera
Oh
at least it tastes good
see you wouldn't think that my actual
birthday could be much better than my
day before my birthday would you and
really it wasn't because I didn't wake
up to the amazingness that was the
secret project but I did have a bloody
fantastic time it was also my friend
gentle voice 30th birthday so we had a
combined birthday extravaganza had three
parts first part amazing Mexican food at
Geraldo's second part quibbles Family
Fun Center I mean really you can't get
much cooler than this I got this been
the birthday wheel and I want a cookie
there was a ridiculously amazing
inflatable obstacle course which I
totally kicked everybody's ass ass
probably the awesomest part of quibbles
is the go-kart racing which we did a lot
and pretty much all day
there was also miniature golf which
Katherine destroyed everyone at
polishing off her victory with a final
hole-in-one and there was laser tag
which I didn't record any of because it
was dark and I was afraid of breaking my
camera that dragon is part three
drinking a lot at bars in Missoula
surrounded by guys with sombreros on
because it's always like that on my
birthday are you gonna do thank you
everyone for making my birthday so
amazing I loved all of my birthday
messages from everyone around the world
I don't think anyone ever in the history
of the world has had a comparable
birthday experience to the one I just
had certainly no one has eaten half of
an anatomical gummy heart washed it down
some mountain Dew and then said thank
you to a hundred people that he's never
met for wishing him such a wonderful
happy birthday and their wishes for my
happy birthday somehow became manifested
in reality and I had one of the happiest
birthdays of my life thank you all so
very much John I will see you tomorrow